Wisconsin lieutenant governor Mandela
Barnes joins us now from Milwaukee
lieutenant governor good morning thank
you for being with us uh I know you
can't share specifics about the
investigation into Jacob Blake's
shooting um but what can you tell us
about the actions that are being
taken uh what I can tell you is that
there is a thorough investigation going
on would thank you for even bringing
this up thank you for uh giving this
moment space it's so important for uh
the American people to realize what's
going on and I can honestly say that I
know about as much as you know I saw the
same video uh that you all saw I saw the
same video that many Americans saw and
that's a person being shot in the back
uh seven times uh I know that our state
department of justice is carrying out
the this investigation as well and I've
intentionally stayed as far away from it
as possible to avoid any sort of uh any
sort of conflict we need this to be done
as thoroughly as possible when you uh
when you saw that video you wrote on
Twitter you've got to be kidding me
uh I I'm wondering the the officer who
shot Jacob Blake Rustin chesy was put on
administrative leave do you believe he
should be
arrested well personally I you know I
just don't see how anybody gets away
with shooting somebody in the back uh
seven times and I feel like
administrative leave is sort of
a it doesn't fit the actions that we saw
and too often we see these repeated
Cycles we see the same scene over and
over again where an unarmed person is
shot and then they end up getting death
Duty uh and I don't think that's fair
many people don't think that's fair as
well um it just feels like you know
there's so much room for uh certain
officers to make mistakes but suspects
cannot make the same mistakes without
fear of losing their lives uh many
people again who we see are unarmed and
Jacob Blake is now paralyzed he's he he
won't be able to walk again uh the
officer has death Duty I don't think I
don't think anybody thinks that that's
spere right now but we are waiting for
this investigation to play out uh
because it's important to find out all
the facts uh but we saw what we saw uh
we just saw that Joe Biden was in
Kenosha yesterday president Trump was
there a few B days before the governor
asked both presidential candidates not
to come for fear of inflaming things do
you think in any way those visits were
beneficial so I'll say that the uh you
know I I joined the governor in
admonishing the the Trump visit because
Trump is a person who has yet to condemn
uh the teenage shooter who was
transported across state lines and
killed two people on our city streets
Donald Trump has done everything to
create even more Division and he's
virtually celebrated uh this person who
was killed two people on our city
streets and severely injured another
that's not what we need at this moment
Kenosha is a city that's healing our
state is a uh state that is grappling
with some racial tension and racial
Injustice and Kenosha is uh grounds zero
for that right now and after you know
the protest like you see so many people
who are coming together who are uniting
who are deciding that this is the time
uh for the city to do better for the
state to do better and Donald Trump's
visit would only it it was one that
sought to divide the city and the state
even more because he's not performing
well in the polls this is a state that
he won four years ago and the only way
that he's able to win is when people
were divided so I am I am glad to see
that while Donald Trump was there there
was a beautiful uh celebration of
community you know you had kids out you
had family members out you had people
just having a great time enjoying
themselves and getting to know one
another and Joe Biden's trip was all
about listening it was different he
didn't make incendiary remarks before he
showed up to Wisconsin he said that as a
presidential candidate uh he wanted to
demonstrate the type of leadership that
he would provide to this nation and that
started by listening and that's exactly
what he did he didn't he didn't come
here to spout off and and say things
that would tear this community further
apart you recently spoke to Jacob
Blake's family uh lieutenant governor
what was their
message so their message is one of one
of hope uh it's one of resilience their
their their message is the kosha story
it's the Wisconsin story it's one that
although there's so much hurt and pain
uh that they do believe that they're
going to get through this and they don't
believe that not just them as a family
uh but us as a community and that's that
that's one of the most amazing things
about it uh I I hate so much that this
family is going through all of this
trouble uh but they want things uh to
get better not just for uh Jacob Blake
but for everybody in kosha everybody
across this uh State everybody across
this country who is dealing with extreme
Injustice because they know that this is
not the way they know that this is not
fair to communities that continue to be
marginalized and if we don't do
something about it uh as Leaders as a
community as elected officials Faith
leaders Business Leaders uh we're going
to be far worse off uh than the worst
examples of things you look at this
continue killing like after Jacob Blake
was shot we still lost two people on the
on on the street two people lost their
lives and this is not any sort of way to
carry on society lieutenant governor
Mandela Barnes thank you so much for
being with us this morning